info based test lab you use real and
virtual devices to test your app these
devices run in a Google Data Center they
contain the latest ap eyes and have
customizable local settings enabling you
to test your app as people around the
world would use it you can let test lab
test your app for you which is called
Robo testing or you can create espresso
instrumentation tests in Android studio
and have test lab run them I will look
at both of these in more detail shortly
you can also run Robo tests from the
Google Play console pre-launch report
each time you upload an app to the
closed or open test tracks the
pre-launch report offers the same Robo
test features as firebase test lab the
benefit of test lab comes from being
able to run tests on a wider range of
devices with more options as well as to
be able to run your own instrumentation
tests okay let's take a close look at
Robo tests when you run a robo test an
application crawler analyzes the
structure of your apps UI and then
explores it methodically simulating user
activity Robo tests capture log files
performance data screenshots of unique
screens as well as annotated video to
show you the simulated user actions it
performed these logs and performance
data and screenshots and videos can help
you determine the cause of crashes and
find issues with your apps UI you can
also use Robo tests to validate bug
fixes and test for regressions this is
because Robo testing simulates the same
user activities in the same order each
time it tests your app there is also an
option to control Robo tests for example
you may want to test a common user
journey or start the crawler at a
specific screen you do this using a
robot script you create these scripts in
Android studio
simply select firebase from the Tools
menu then click record Robo script
use it to guide robo tests now record
and upload your scripts to firebase test
lab in addition to a regular crawl from
the beginning of your app you can test
up to three deep links here the crawler
follows the link and then exercises your
app for an additional 30 seconds
reporting on anything it finds in the
same way as it does for the remain test
Robo tests can also sign into your app
using either a Google login or your own
custom login credentials Robo tests are
a great way to get started with app
testing with minimal effort on your part
however for a truly high quality app you
will almost certainly need to create
your own instrumentation tests which
fire based test lab can then run for you
you can create these test scripts in
Android studio either manually or you
can recall them using record espresso
tests on the run menu you record your
test script by interacting with your app
when done saving your test strip locally
for more details on recording test
scripts check out the Android tool time
video create UI test with espresso test
recorder there is a link in the video
details to get the most out of espresso
tests the key is to modularize your
tests creating test snippets for the
functions used in the majority of your
tests such as logging in or filling out
a search form you can then invoke these
snippets from your test scripts whenever
you need these common functions then as
you update your app use this special
espresso test recorder to quickly
re-record the snippets where there have
been changes you can then run these test
scripts locally or load the suite of
tests into your continuous integration
server and get the assurance that you
haven't broken your app at each update
and of course you can upload the test
scripts to firebase test lab you can
then choose to run the tests on a
selection of over 50 virtual and
physical devices many of them available
with a range of Android versions other
options
include testing your app in different
languages or screen orientations and
more you can also run your tests in fire
based test lab from your continuous
integration server you can find details
on how to do this from the link in the
video description
espresso test recorder enables you to
quickly and easily create tests for all
parts of your app you can then use the
features of a continuous integration
server the pre-launch report and
firebase test lab to automate your
testing improving your app quality while
freeing your time to focus on
development to find out about this and
other features and get tips to grow your
app or game business
check out the PlayBook app available on
Google Play thanks for watching
[Music]